we rediscovered a sensitive area that
you feel through the anterior or front
top vaginal wall and doctors John Perry
and I named this area after dr. Ernst
Craven burg he named it the Griffin burg
spot and that could shortened to the
g-spot but dr. Griffin Burke wrote about
sensitivity in women various forms of
sensitivity one of them he wrote about
was this sensitivity that you feel
through the anterior or the top wall of
the vagina and we also if I may go back
and explain I was teaching women how to
do Kegel exercises for a condition
called urinary stress incontinence
that's when a woman jumps coughs or
sneezes and drills a little urine and I
was teaching this with biofeedback and
what we found was that some women who
came to have stress incontinence treated
had very strong pelvic muscles where
women who have stress incontinence
urinary stress incontinence have weak
muscles and these women with the strong
muscle said oh I only lose some fluid
from my urethra the tube you urinate
through during sexual stimulation and it
seems to be an area of my in my vagina
that when it's stimulated it kind of
produces this expulsion of fluid and so
we looked at these women we identified
that this is what Griffin berg had or
others had called female ejaculation we
analyzed the fluid and found it was
statistically significantly different
from urine and it's about 3 to 5 cc's it
looks like watered-down fat-free milk so
we identified the phenomenon of female
ejaculation and how the fluid that's
expelled from the urethra is different
from urine we then had nurse
practitioners or physicians do
examinations of 400 women looking for
areas of sensitivity in the vagina and
if a woman was lying on her back and
fingers were put into the vagina with I
could come here motion just look at
different areas of the vagina like a
clock and most women had sensitivity
between 11:00 and 1:00 o'clock which is
the area that we have named the Griffin
burg spot and this area began to swell
as it was
stimulated so we did more research and
this is what we found this is why we
named this after dr. Griffin burger
because in 1950 he wrote an article
about this female or the expulsion of
fluid and the sensitivity of this area
that you feel through the front or top
or anterior wall of the vagina
first of all I try to help women who say
they have problems having an orgasmic
response I try to help these women to
realize that there's a wide range of
orgasmic responses and women and they
have to find out what it is they like
and what it is brings them pleasure and
Gina and I in our book safe encounters
Whipple and Ogden develop something
called an extra genital matrix in which
we list
16:15 types of touch and 36 parts of the
body and we give this to people to help
map their body using a scale of one to
ten what feels good to you do you like
to have your partner's suckling your
toes or stroked the back of your neck
and it helps people to become aware of
what it is they like so you have to
first of all become aware of what brings
you sensual and sexual pleasure and then
you have to acknowledge this to yourself
and say yes you know I do that's what I
do enjoy then the hardest part for most
people is communicate what they find
pleasurable what they like to their
partner and we can't put women or men
really into a pattern of this only one
way to respond sensually and sexually we
have many sexual responses and that's
what I try to help women to see find out
what they like what brings them pleasure
what brings them satisfaction and then
to be able to communicate that to a
partner if they choose to have sexual
experiences with a partner
what we have found out is that there are
women who can have orgasm from imagery
alone or what my colleague calls
thinking off Gina Ogden who's a sex
therapist did her doctoral dissertation
on easily orgasmic women and from her
sample of women 64% of the women who are
easily orgasmic stated that they could
have orgasm from imagery alone no
touching the body no looking in anything
just from thinking and so we had these
women come into my human physiology
laboratory and we tested their responses
from imagery alone and from genital self
stimulation and we did that in a counter
balanced way so that one would not
influence the other and their orgasmic
responses were exactly the same in terms
of increases in blood pressure increases
in heart rate increases in the diameter
of the pupil and their pain and tactile
thresholds there was no significant
difference and so we documented that
women do indeed have orgasm from imagery
or thinking and then we have studied
some of these same women in the fMRI
unit to look at the areas of the brain
that are activated during the orgasm so
yes women can certainly have pleasurable
sexual responses without hurt the one or
anyone else touching her body